UBIQUITOUS, SOMETIMES REAL TIME
VIDEO CONVEYING IN HUMAN TERMS
THE WAR IN RUSSIA.
THIS IS WHAT REMAINS OF AN
APARTMENT BUILDING IN MAYRIUPOL.
SO MUCH OF THE CITY LOOKS LIKE
THAT.
YOU CAN SEE THROUGH THE SKELETON
OF THAT BUILDING.
THIS WOMAN DECIDED IT WAS TIME
TO FLEE.
SOME VIDEO OF WHAT THEIR LIVING
ARRANGE WRMTS UP TO THAT POINT.
NO HEAT OR RUNNING WATER.
THEY TOOK SHELTER FROM THE
STRIKES.
>> TONIGHT THEY'RE SAFE, MOST OF
THEM.
I SPOKE TO HER JUST BEFORE AIR
TIME.
JULIA, THANKS FOR TALKING TO US.
WHAT WAS IT LIKE WHEN THE
BOMBING BEGAN IN MARIUPOL?
>> IT WAS -- FOR THE FIRST FEW
DAYS WE DIDN'T REALIZE HOW BAD
IT WAS.
I DIDN'T REALIZE BECAUSE IT WAS
FAR AWAY.
IT WAS IN ANOTHER PART OF THE
CITY.
AND FOR THAT MOMENT I THOUGHT MY
DISTRICT WAS SAFE, BUT LATER
THEY CAME THERE AND THEY
SURROUNDED THE CITY.
SO MY DISTRICT, WHICH IS ALSO A
CITY, IT WAS PRETTY MUCH
DAMAGED.
>> I UNDERSTAND THERE WAS A
DIRECT HIT NEAR YOUR BUILDING ON
I THINK IT WAS MARCH 12th?
>> YES, IT WAS MARCH 12th AND
THERE WAS A DIRECT HIT ON MY
BUILDING AND TODAY I EVEN GOT TO
SEE A VIDEO OF MY HOUSE, HOW IT
LOOKS NOW.
NOT MY VIDEO BUT SOMEONE AND IT
IS BURNED DOWN SO BADLY, LIKE
NOTHING IS LEFT.
>> WHERE WAS YOUR APARTMENT?
>> MY APARTMENT WAS ON THE
SECOND FLOOR WHICH IS YOU HAVE
TO RUN VERY QUICKLY BUT IT'S
ADVENTUROUS WHEN THERE ARE
STREET FIGHTS BUT WE LEFT
BEFORE.
>> HOW LONG WERE YOU LIVING
WITHOUT HEAT, WITHOUT HOT WATER
IN THAT APARTMENT?
WE HAVE SOME VIDEO OF YOU AND
YOUR FAMILY IN THE APARTMENT.
>> YES.
IT WAS SINCE THE 2nd OF MARCH.
ON THE 2nd OF MARCH THEY TURNED
OFF EVERYTHING BUT GAS AND THEY
TURNED OFF GAS A FEW DAYS LATER.
>> IT LOOKS -- I MEAN, IT MUST
HAVE BEEN JUST MISERABLE.
IT IS FREEZING COLD AT THIS TIME
OF YEAR.
>> YEAH, IT WAS MINUS 7 ON THE
STREETS MINE WAS FROM 5 TO 7
DEGREES.
WE HAD TO SLEEP IN OUR JACKETS
AND WE HAD LIKE FIVE SWEATERS
AND T-SHIRTS ON AND WE SLEPT
UNDER ALL THE BLANKETS WE HAD
BUT I WAS COLD ANYWAY.
>> CAN YOU TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT WHAT IT'S LIKE TO BE
LIVING IN A PLACE THAT IS BEING
REPEATEDLY BOMBED AND WHICH IS
CLEARLY JUST BEING BOMBED TO
TOTAL DESTRUCTION, TO BE ON THE
RECEIVING END OF THAT, TO NOT
KNOW WHERE THE NEXT SHELL IS
GOING TO LAND, HOW DO YOU COPE
WITH THAT?
>> I ACTUALLY COULDN'T COPE WITH
THAT ANYWAY BECAUSE I COULDN'T
SEE MY FRIENDS, I COULDN'T TALK
TO THEM.
I COULD ONLY TALK TO MY FAMILY
AND IT'S A FEELING OF
HELPLESSNESS AND IT'S THE
FEELINGS THAT YOU DON'T KNOW
WHEN IT ENDS.
BECAUSE WHEN YOU HEAR NEWS, YOU
CAN HAVE UPS AND DOWNS.
AND WHEN YOU DIDN'T HAVE
ANYTHING BUT THE SOUND OF
BOMBING YOU ONLY HAVE DOWNS AND
YOU'RE ONLY FEELING MORE AND
MORE MISERABLE.
YOU KNOW THAT NOWHERE IS SAFE.
>> IN MARIUPOL WE'VE SEEN IMAGES
OF PEOPLE BEING BURIED IN MASS
GRAVES, PEOPLE -- THERE'S
REPORTS OF NEIGHBORS BURYING
NEIGHBORS IN THEIR BACKYARDS
BECAUSE THERE'S NOWHERE ELSE TO
PUT THEM.
WHAT DID YOU DO FOR WATER?
>> WATER WAS THE MAIN QUESTION
ACTUALLY.
THERE WAS MELTED SNOW.
WE MELTED SNOW FOR -- WE DID IT
A FEW TIMES BUT WE DON'T HAVE
MUCH SNOW IN MARIUPOL.
WHEN WE DIDN'T HAVE SNOW WE USED
THE WATER FROM THE -- LIKE
RUNNING WATER THAT WE HAD SAVED
BECAUSE WE HAD SAVED A WHOLE
BUNCH AND BOTTLES.
AND THE THING IS THAT OUR WATER,
RUNNING WATER, ISN'T THAT GOOD
TO DRINK SO IT HAD THIS -- NOT
VERY GOOD TASTE AND THIS CAN
DAMAGE YOUR HOUSE -- HEALTH IF
YOU DRINK IT TOO LONG.
AND MELTED SNOW WAS QUITE OKAY.
THERE WAS ALSO HEAT IN THE PIPE
WITH HEATED WATER NEAR OUR HOUSE
BUT YOU COULDN'T DRINK THIS
WATER.
WE GOT SOME OF THIS WATER TO
FLUSH THE TOILET AND TO WASH THE
FLOORS.
>> YOU'VE MADE IT NOW TO BERLIN.
WHAT HAPPENS NOW?
>> I'LL FIND A SCHOOL WHERE I
CAN GRADUATE AND PASS THE EXAMS
AND SO ON.
I WANT TO COME BACK TO UKRAINE
BUT IF NOTHING CHANGE, I WILL
TRY TO GET HIGHER EDUCATION
HERE.
I TRY TO CONTINUE WORKING.
I WORK AS PRIVATE TEACHER FOR
KIDS, GERMAN LANGUAGE, SO I TRY
TO KEEP UP.
>> I KNOW YOUR MOM IS WITH YOU.
HAVE YOU HEARD FROM YOUR
STEPFATHER AND GRANDPARENTS?
>> MY STEPFATHER IS IN WESTERN
UKRAINE NOW WITH MY DOGS.
THEY ARE DOING OKAY.
I GOT FRESH NEWS FROM MY
GRANDPARENTS TODAY.
THEY'VE BEEN EVACUATED TO
DONETSK.
THEIR FLAT HAS ALSO BURNED.
THERE WAS A FIRE AND I SAW VIDEO
OF THEIR HOUSE AND IT'S REALLY,
REALLY BAD.
IT HAS BURNED FROM THE FIRST
FLOOR SO THEY'RE ALIVE AND WE'VE
SEEN SOME THINGS, NOT MANY.
THEY'RE IN DONETSK AND THEY'RE
DECIDING WHAT SHOULD THEY